vends des habitants médusés des maisons
éventrées des flammes et des débris ce
quartier résidentiel de marioupol a été
bombardé il ya une frappe aérienne sur
un secteur pavillonnaire c'est un soldat
ukrainien qui filme et communique par
talkie walkie nous inspectons la zone
les blessés ont été évacués à l'hôpital
d'après nos observations pas d'autres
victimes
un peu plus loin un bâtiment de services
d'urgence vient lui aussi d'être
bombardés à lattes ce pompier amène les
kits de premiers secours
ces hommes si elle est à peine en
équilibre sur les décombres à la
recherche de victimes
mario paul est devenu une ville martyre
au neuvième jour de sièges russe plus de
1200 habitants déjà été tués d'après le
maire les frappes aériennes ont atteint
cet hôpital pour enfants une maternité
créant une onde de choc dans le pays et
partout dans le monde il y a eu trois
morts dont une enfant l'union européenne
comme les autorités ukrainiennes dénoncé
un crime de guerre
la frappe aérienne sur la maternité est
la preuve ultime la preuve que le
génocide des ukrainiens c est en cours
de son côté l'armée russe qualifie le
bombardement de mise en scène de la part
des ukrainiens il affirme que c'est
bâtiment abritait une base nationaliste
les rues de la ville sont jonchées de
corps que les bombardements incessants
pêche de ramasser quand malgré tout les
secours y parviennent les cadavres sont
emmenés dans cette fosse commune le
cimetière est à l'autre bout de la ville
impossible d'y accéder ses hommes l'ont
creusé il ya tout juste deux jours sur
25 mètres de long
la seule chose que je veux c'est que
tout soit terminé on ne sait pas qui est
coupable qui est à l'origine de tout ça
mais on a ces personnes
mario paul est aujourd'hui coupé du
monde plus de télécommunications il n'ya
plus de chauffage plus d'eau dans les
maisons l'eau de ce puits est prise
d'assaut par les habitants